[Musique]
le temps passe minois aux requêtes on
oublie pas
jamais vous n'aviez entendu parler d'un
système de partage de contrats sur les
moyens je me on a trouvé des documents
inédits qui contredisent la version
donnée par franck pineau à la commission
charbonneau faisait des documents que
j'aurais aimé souhaité avoir ajustements
pour confronter des témoins et à laval
on a aussi fait des découvertes
troublant en fait à laval et en suisse
je vais vous convaincre je ne suis pas
un homme seul
reste-t-il de l'argent caché quelque
part après des années d'un régime
corrompu vous avez versé de l'argent à
une société dans le monde qu des
caribous caribou c'était gilles
vaillancourt
c'est une chose que j'ignore
et si marie maude denis bienvenue à
enquête
2 voici la fin du règne de gilles
vaillancourt comme vous ne l'avez jamais
vu
dans ces vidéos de filature obtenu par
enquête les policiers pili faisait geste
du maire qui règne sans partage sur
laval depuis plus de 20 ans
contrairement à d'autres stratagèmes
qu'on voyait dans d'autres vélos dans
d'autres sphères de la société
c'est que c'était dirigé par le maire
la police s'intéresse à ces rencontres
dans la rue dans des restaurants et même
la nuit dans un stationnement
les policiers constatent alors que le
maire fait des manoeuvres de contre
filature il change de direction quand
ils se déplacent et il utilise plusieurs
téléphones craignant à être sur écoute
électronique à quel moment vous avez
pris conscience que vaillancourt là est
à la tête d'une organisation criminelle
j'ai perfectionné à ses commerces ou
dirait j'avais la conviction que c'était
ça
le 9 mai 2013 gilles vaillancourt et 36
autres personnes sont accusées à la
suite d'une retentissante opérations du
tac
j'ai bien des nôtres
et beaucoup d'arguments à faire valoir
devant le tribunal où le mans porter le
maire est même accusé de gangstérisme
mais retrouver l'argent volé aux
lavallois c'est un gros défi
le jour de leur arrestation
gilles vaillancourt et ses coaccusés
sont interrogés au quartier général de
la sûreté du québec loin des caméras
télévision
les enquêteurs s'efforcent de retracer
des millions de dollars plusieurs
refusent de coopérer
[Musique]
millions
j'avais avancé
est ce que c'est parce que vous placer
cet argent l'eau dans des comptes
offshore
j'ai été pour mener
le tableau
ça nous permet d'obtenir des
renseignements sur des personnes au pays
oui sans doute
trois ans plus tard l'ex maire
vaillancourt plaide coupable à des
accusations de fraude de complot et
d'abus de confiance
il remet des millions de dollars et un
appartement à la balle
d'argent qu'on a eue de monsieur
vaillancourt la chercher et il ya
environ dix millions
dix millions si beaucoup mais notre
enquête montre que des millions de
dollars d'origine douteuse donc
peut-être encore dans des paradis
fiscaux
on voit à étudier ça de façon détaillée
et 6 et des repos qui sont réalistes et
on a des bonnes chances de succès on
voit les attentes et ce aux frais
compter sur moi je vous dirai ça fait un
beau cadeau qu'on trouve dans l'argent
qui échappe aux révèle
[Musique]
retenez cette date le 3 novembre et le
jour les citoyens de laval ont dit non à
la corruption le 3 novembre 2013 marc
demers est élu maire de laval il
participera par la suite aux
négociations qui vont mener ou plaidoyer
de culpabilité de gilles vaillancourt
large mais ça surtout d'envoyer un
signal fort cette culture s'est terminée
une culture de poudre vin versés aux
élus érigés en système bien avant d'être
maire marc demers était enquêteur à la
police de laval c'est enquête l'amène à
perquisitionner dans des entreprises
appartenant à la famille vaillancourt
furieux gilles vaillancourt tentera de
faire dérailler l'enquêté
c'est moi que tu as donné ta job lac à
sec font effet il faudra attendre 30 ans
et la commission charbonneau pour
découvrir les rouages du système
entrepreneurs ou les firmes d'ingénierie
qui a obtenu le contrat devait redonner
aux parties en argent comptant pour la
plupart du temps 2%
la balance entre eux
maître simon tremblay était aux
premières loges de la commission
charbonneau comme procureur il a
interrogé plusieurs acteurs clés dont
pierre lambert un avocat qui cachait de
l'argent détourné par l'organisation de
gilles vaillancourt est ce que vous vous
souvenez du montant de cette première
remise d'argent je me suis dit mon temps
parce qu elle dit ils vont tous les deux
cent mille dollars dans sa valise d'auto
il me met un carton dans lesquelles il
ya de l'argent
pierre lambert cacher l'argent comptant
dans un mini entrepôts puis il remettait
dix hommes à différentes personnes sur
demande
dans cette vidéo jamais diffusé on voit
le moment où pierre lambert remet des
liasses d'argent aux enquêteurs de la
commission charbonneau
[Musique]
heureusement que vous avez récolté
approximativement 2 millions et pour
lequel il vous reste environ 720 mille
dollars que vous nous avez remis ces
témoignages secoue le québec
et les nouvelles de laval ont des échos
à des milliers de kilomètres jusque dans
les banques suisses le gouvernement
suisse déclenche aussi sa propre enquête
je savais qu'il y avait eu des démarches
avec la suisse met à rêver que les
autorités suisses eurent mis à l'enquêté
nous avons obtenu des milliers de pages
de documents confidentiels de cette
enquête menée en suisse on y apprend que
des 87 gilles vaillancourt ouvre une
série de comptes en banque à cette
époque il est déjà un politicien
puissants comme président du comité
exécutif de laval mais sur ce document
il se présente plutôt comme un simple
commerçant et se choisit un nom de code
caribou
puis à partir de 2004 gilles
vaillancourt ajoute une couche d'opacité
en se cachant derrière une société du
panama administré par un avocat de
genève
créé 2 7 millions de dollars d'argent
volé s'accumulent dans les comptes de la
compagnie
c'est de là que provient la grande part
de l'argent que gilles vaillancourt
remet aux autorités quand il plaide
coupable en 2016 la première question
qu'on se pose c'est pourquoi
à quoi sert ce genre de deux toiles
leconte et dati corporatives michèle
picard est un spécialiste des crimes
financiers qui a travaillé comme
analyste pour la grc il n'est pas
certain que le maire de laval ait besoin
de tant de comptes à l'étranger pour
gérer son patrimoine financier pour
savez à cause des remarques y avait les
cacher un succès il ya des gens qui se
cacha pas bon en parler
des enquêteurs suisses ont trouvé bien
d'autres choses à commencer par un
coffret de sûreté que gilles
vaillancourt posséder dans les voûtes de
la banque julius baer dans ce coffret
les policiers découvrent document
étrange un avocat québécois déclarent
être le prénom de gilles vaillancourt
pour une société à numéro au québec
[Musique]
joint au téléphone l'avocat dit tout
ignorer de cette compagnie
j'ai agi comme
la famille vers
[Musique]
cette compagnie n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
impossible de savoir à quoi elle a servi
et le prénom et tout le signe
caractéristique bien souvent de
transactions à l'étranger où on veut
éloigner le plus possible les traces
effacer les traces ou perdent les traces
pour après ça ne plus être capable de
remonter à la source
plusieurs doutent en effet que gilles
vaillancourt et remis tout l'argent
détourné avant de prendre le chemin de
la prison
quand on parlait autrefois du maire de
laval vont évoquer plusieurs dizaines
millions de dollars l'on parle de 9
millions aux alentours de 9 millions de
dollars est ce que c'est possible bien
caché de l'argent quelque part vous
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on sache vaut
écouter sait le faire il l'a fait à bill
même
e
en suisse les enquêteurs ont découvert
bien des secrets inconnue des policiers
au québec
gilles vaillancourt n'est pas seul
lavallois posséder des comptes de banque
en suisse pierre lambert aussi a ouvert
une série de contes au fil des années
ils y déposent de l'argent depuis 1981
donc je me fiais votre réponse je
pourrais je me trompe pas en disant que
vous n'êtes pas un proche de monsieur
bien qu on peut on n'est pas un proche
mais tout le monde est plein champ et
très proches puis ya des gens qui se
peuvent se vanter des preuves et
d'autres personnes qui peuvent
s'imaginer qu'on est proche parce que
effectivement on ne les ans d'aller
pouvoir les peler réponse est bien
longue ma question qui est assez simple
où nous étions un proche ou non de
monsieur gilles vaillancourt jeu pour
savoir ce qu'il y en a je pense selon
vous soyez au moins de nom
pourtant selon les documents bancaires
que nous avons obtenus
pierre lambert a transféré
personnellement des centaines de
milliers de dollars à gilles
vaillancourt en suisse dont 4 fois 200
mille dollars en 2006 et 2007 l'argent
transfert en somme importante et en
chiffres arrondis c'est assez typique
les gens ne prennent pas mais ils le
font toujours quand même dans des cas de
fraude on voit souvent ça les transferts
de mon temps en chiffreront 50 cent
mille deux cents niel nous avons
contacté m lambert pour comprendre c'est
étonnant transferts de fonds
[Musique]
mais moi j'ai les documents qui montrent
que eu des versements directs de votre
compte chez ubs
donc nous on se demande si vous étiez
pas un genre de quessy pour gilles
vaillancourt en suisse
[Musique]
dans ce fax manuscrit signé par pierre
lambert en 1993 on découvre un autre
versement de 130 mille dollars est la
référence où nos codes caribou les liens
entre pierre lambert et gilles
vaillancourt en suisse seraient étalés
sur des années vous avez versé de
l'argent à une société dont le nom de
code et caribou caribou c'était gilles
vaillancourt
par l'entremise de son avocat pierre
lambert affirme qu'il ne connaissait pas
nécessairement l'identité des détenteurs
des comptes est l'objet des transactions
en question
pierre lambert est arrêtée accusée au
criminel le même jour que gilles
vaillancourt
[Musique]
déjà les enquêteurs le soupçonnent de
cacher de l'argent ailleurs qu'à laval
oui ça fait
deux escales
dans cette vidéo enregistrée au quartier
général de la sûreté du québec et obtenu
d'une source confidentielle un policier
cherche à faire passer pierre lambert
aux aveux là
c'est parce que placer cet argent l'eau
dans les grandes heures show
j'ai pour toi
ce jour là pierre lambert refuse de
collaborer mais on a peut-être trouvé
une partie de l'argent que les policiers
cherchaient
après la pause destination miami qu'est
ce qui se cache derrière le conte 12
gilles vaillancourt en floride
ils pressent pas l'intéressé donc le
maire vaillancourt s'est détaché d'un
actif pour le mettre au nom d'une
personne
[Musique]
un condo en floride ça peut être très
utile pour profiter du soleil mais vous
allez voir que dans l'histoire de gilles
vaillancourt ça peut aussi être billets
pratiques pour mettre de l'argent à
l'abri des regards
[Musique]
notre recherche de l'argent caché par
l'ex maire de laval gilles vaillancourt
et par l'avocat pierre lambert nous
amène ici sur les plages de miami en
floride
en 2006 des pousses de gilles
vaillancourt achète un condo tropicana
sur la prestigieuse avenue carling
le vendeur est une obscure compagnie des
bahamas fleury mme cette propriété qui
vaut aujourd'hui un million de dollars
n'a pas été remise aux autorités lorsque
vaillancourt a plaidé coupable
la mystérieuse compagnie fleury mme a
par la suite transféré un montant
équivalent au prix du condo vers le
compte de l'avocat suisse de gilles
vaillancourt
c'est effectivement la probité du
creusot était celle de monsieur
vaillancourt par une personne était
reposé
l'argent par la poche gauche par la
poche droite une des suggestions qu'on
pourrait faire ce que le principal
intéressé dont le merveilleux en cours
s'est détaché d'un actif pour le mettre
au nom d'une personne donc si lui
poursuivi l'actif et n'est inattaquable
puis en 2010 l'argent est transféré dans
un autre compte appartenant à l'avocat
pierre lambert
c'est ta moko là
avait manifestement des relations
financières personnelles et occulte avec
monsieur gilles vaillancourt à l'époque
nous avons sollicité l'avis d'experts un
des défis les transferts d'argent
soulève beaucoup de questions notamment
parce que pierre lambert représenter la
ville de laval dans nombreuses aussi à
titre d'avocat
40 sous à l'insu de l'ensemble du corps
décideurs de la municipalité fait des
transactions qui sont douteuses qui sont
manifestement fait un souci délibéré
d'être cachés les dissimuler
mais c'est préoccupant c'est très pris
acte est ce que vous êtes à la fois
l'avocat d'une municipalité est très
impliqué activement dans ce genre de
choses je vois difficilement comment on
peut le faire
c'est pour moi une combative vous votre
réponse n'avait pas d'eau non vous êtes
donné de l'argent compte non
la commission charbonneau à taden et
pierre lambert pour comprendre l'ampleur
de son rôle dans le détournement
d'argent à laval à part roger des bosses
que d'autres personnes qui vous ont
remis de l'argent comptant à laval ou
autres municipalités
il ya personne qui me donnait d'autres
jacottin laval on sait qu'il ya une
autre question qu'on pourrait vous poser
lit on n'a jamais entendu parler de son
rôle avec je viens en cours en suisse
même la commission charbonneau où il
disait qu'il ne connaissait pas vraiment
gilles vaillancourt je n'étais pas en
mesure de vous dire que dans ce cas là
est ce qu'il ya eu ou non des fausses
déclarations mais si c'est le cas c'est
très grave
pierre lambert nie avoir menti à la
commission charbonneau et ce n'est pas
le seul maire avec pierre lambert
faisait secrètement des affaires en
suisse
[Musique]
cette semaine à enquête laval la ville
de tous les scandales
en décembre 2012 l'émission enquête lève
le voile sur la longue histoire des
soupçons de corruption entourant les
maires de laval le reportage affirme que
l'ex maire claude lefebvre et son
collecteur de fonds aurait touché 10
millions de dollars
le journaliste christian latreille
questions sans détour le prédécesseur de
gilles vaillancourt show du lys lefebvre
cet argent-là été transportés dans des
valises à montréal jusqu'au bermudes
ensuite de sa été transféré en suisse
monsieur
c'est de la bombe écoutez si vous avez
des preuves mais telle est l'offre je
dis je les comprends qu'à ce moment là
je suis coupable de fraude ce sont des
insinuations quant à moi et bien sûr
comme me révolte j'en ai fait un
entrevue mais pour quelle raison
dix ans plus tard les documents
bancaires secrets obtenus par enquêtes
montrent qu'au moment de cette entrevue
claude lefebvre détenait bel et bien de
l'argent en suisse au nom d'une
fondation incorporé au liechtenstein
ce compte de banque secret a été ouvert
en 1985 quelques semaines seulement
avant son élection pour un deuxième
mandat à la mairie de laval
au début des années 2000 claude lefebvre
qui détenait près d'un million et demi
de dollars si on voit qu'à une
continuité dans la pratique de mer à
l'autre
on est en droit de se poser la question
est ce cap alors une corruption
systémique quasi revoici en plus de mon
salaire déluge pour y chercher une coupe
de cent mille coups de millions on se
fait plaisir un tournant en débauche qui
gérait les avoirs du mr lefebvre en
suisse nul autre que pierre lambert
nos documents montrent que c'est lui qui
donne les instructions de retrait aux
banquiers et les principales sorties de
fonds sont dirigés vers son propre
compte en suisse
plus de six cent mille dollars entre
2002 et 2010
on sait que vous avez dit monsieur
lefebvre à gérer son compte en suisse
je peux comme en hd joue son
jeu
il ya même eu plusieurs transferts
d'argent dans votre propre compte chez
ubs au cours des années
l'empreinte de pierre lambert est
visible partout à laval comme avocat il
a piloté nombreuses aussi sous
l'administration vaillancourt dont
l'implantation de ce campus
universitaire
la construction d'un amphithéâtre ou
coûts de 180 millions de dollars
la place belle est un centre sportif
ultra moderne situé au coeur du nouveau
centre ville de laval
de plus c'est un organisme à but non
lucratif et non la ville qui gère le
projet en 2010 alors que le site de la
place belle n'était qu'un terrain vague
l'émission enquête avait questionné
gilles vaillancourt pour avoir confié la
gestion de ce projet à pierre lambert le
porte parole est un avocat de la firme
dunton rainville payé par laval est ce
que ça ne prenne pas flins à du copinage
garder en effet quatre fois jusqu'ici
bien de pas eu de copinage
alors pourquoi il ne reste la 5e fois
l'enquète suisse nous fait découvrir des
liens jusqu'ici inconnu entre pierre
lambert et un urbaniste impliqués dans
ces projets
on février 2009 michel colin ouvre lui
aussi un compte en suisse avec l'aide de
pierre lambert à qui il accorde une
procuration
personne qui a qui me recommandations
pour pouvoir ouvrir un compte de banque
c'est tout
j'ai abîmé en mer il aimait tant
d'années jamais
michelle collins nous explique que
pierre lambert était son avocat
personnel à l'époque au même moment sa
firme d'urbanisme décroche plusieurs
mandats dans le cadre de la construction
du campus universitaire de laval et de
la place belle dans cette lettre du 14
octobre 2009 on voit que michelle
collins écrite directement la pierre
lambert pour l'obtention de mandats et
puis si nous on nous explique finalement
l'ouverture d'un compte en suisse a rien
à voir avec ville de laval parce qu'il
ya quand même un problème il pourrait en
avoir un dans la mesure où et quand même
une relation parallèle entre l'avocat et
ses urbanistes là toujours en octobre
2009 michelle collins vers 6000 $ dans
un compte suisse appartenant à pierre
lambert dans une lettre qu'il nous a
fait parvenir michelle collins affirme
n'avoir jamais verser d'argent tenant
lieu de commission en lien avec des
contrats avec la ville de laval ou dans
l'objectif d'obtenir de tels contrats
vous savez le conflit d'intérêts c'est
particulier c'est que on n'a pas
nécessairement à prouver qu'il ya eu
réellement confiné terré l'apparence de
conflit d'intérêts et tout si grave que
le profit d'un terrien en soit les
enquêteurs suisses remarque aussi un
dépôt suspect de 250 mille dollars d'un
compte bancaire de michelle collins
trois mois à peine après son ouverture
les sommes sont envoyés par l'avocat
suisse de gilles vaillancourt et dans un
document officiel ce dernier affirme que
l'argent appartient au maire
vaillancourt
est-ce qu'il doit des sommes à gilles
vaillancourt à ces gens là est ce que
ces gens là lui doit des sommes est ce
qu'ils vont ces gens là vont lui
remettre davantage de somme si son
contrat c'est tous ces questionnements
look ça soulève des questions que nous
avons posées à michelle collins qui nie
catégoriquement avoir reçu de l'argent
appartenant à vaillancourt on a un
virement profit de gilles vaillancourt
qui aboutit dans votre compte
jamais jamais jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais selon
michelle collins ce montant se serait
retrouvé dans son compte bancaire sans
sa connaissance
les enquêteurs ont relevé d'autres
transactions qui soulève des questions
sur le rôle joué par pierre lambert en
suisse des versements en provenance de
laval et de monaco
pierre lambert apparaît au sens d'une
nébuleuse de comptes secrets liés à la
balle
en 2018 ils contrôlent 5 millions et
demi de dollars dans divers comptes
bancaires
comprendre le rôle clé que pourrait
avoir ou avoir eu l'avocat c'est une
boîte de pandore qui va m'amener j'ai
aucune idée cours
au retour on va vous révéler qu'il y a
dix ans des enquêteurs en suisse on
savait déjà beaucoup sur laval comment
se fait-il que leurs rapports soient
restés sur une tablette ici
ça c'est sans doute parce que ça ne se
pressant mass market policière donc
comme toute enquête policière est
confidentiel
[Musique]
à genève les autorités ont découvert que
pierre lambert et d'aucuns d'un réseau
de comptes bancaires secrets
lorsqu on le place au centre du
diagramme et qui fait affaire avec
plusieurs autres entreprises et
individus il devient un joueur central
les suisses le soupçonne de faire du
blanchiment d'argent et de la corruption
lorsqu'on pense que le réseau ne
correspond pas aux affaires de
l'individu on pense à différents
stratagèmes financiers à caractère
frauduleux blanchiment d'argent
l'évasion fiscale du tourneur d'art jean
pierre lambert nous répond qu'au
contraire toutes les transactions faites
en suisse sont justifiées par sa
pratique d'avocat d'affaires les
documents obtenus par enquêtes montrent
toutefois que les comptes utilisés par
pierre lambert en suisse sont des
comptes personnels
ça rend la théorie de du service
professionnel beaucoup plus
chambranlante
parce qu'un professionnel utilisent des
outils professionnels 4 utilise ton
compte personnel
quelque part ça implique l'individu
lui-même à ce moment-là ça apporte notre
intérêt encore plus à fouiller sur la
nature des transferts qui l'a fait à la
fin de son témoignage à la commission
charbonneau pierre lambert affirme qu'il
n'a pas profité personnellement de sa
participation dans les stratagèmes de
corruption et de collusion à laval un
modèle la présidente monsieur le
commissaire la motivation de légistes
n'ont jamais été les portugais ou la
recherche de quelques récompenses aux
avantages
personnels
après son passage à la commission
charbonneau ils vident un des quatre
comptes en banque qu'il possède aux
bahamas un autre paradis fiscal il
transfère près d'un million de dollars
vers la suisse en 2018 m pierre lambert
avait toujours 5,5 millions dollars dans
divers comptes en suisse je tape au
coureur de saur chaque coureur qui avait
une cachette chez tous assortis à
commission charbonneau
à laval au palais de justice les
procédures se poursuivent pour juger
ceux qui ont participé à un vaste
complot de fraude pierre lambert
continue de se défendre d'avoir caché
des pots de vin malgré ces admissions à
la commission charbonneau les autorités
canadiennes ignore alors qu'ils
contrôlent plus de 5 millions de dollars
en suisse à s'impliquer dans le landeau
c'est de laval
gilles vaillancourt lui rend finalement
les armes et plaide coupable en suisse
les autorités frappe toutefois un mur
depuis l'europe les enquêteurs
n'arrivent pas à prouver que les
différents montants ayant transité
constitue le produit d'une activité
criminelle
malheureusement les forces policières
suisse partait avec un pas en arrière
pour statuer sur le blanchiment d'argent
il devrait être en mesure de prouver que
la transaction initiale était l'objet de
revenus gémina lisez le programme été
qui se faisaient probablement ici au
canada
quatre ans après le début de leur
enquête les suisse transmette donc aux
autorités canadiennes la preuve
accumulée ils s'en remettent à elle pour
suivre la trace de l'argent mais peu de
temps après les accusations contre
pierre lambert tombe en raison des trop
grandes et les écouler ils ont invoqué
des délais trop longs qu'ils ont eu
raison ils sont au revoir et puis procès
c'est fini voilà les comptes bancaires
de pierre lambert qui avaient été gelées
sont alors débloqué et les informations
sensibles récoltés par les suisses n'ont
pas de suite nous en révélant l'étendue
pour la première fois le directeur des
poursuites criminelles et pénales du
québec a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue
la volonté politique est celle ci on a
des motifs d'enquêté de pousser plus
loin ou de récupérer des sommes d'argent
dans la recommandation un clair nous
allons continuer à récupérer des sommes
d'argent moi personnellement c'est moi
tu parles personnellement même si la fin
d'exercice c'est du un pour un stadiste
a coûté 5 millions pour aller chercher 5
millions supplémentaires cependant ce
que ça vaut la peine nous avons tenté
d'obtenir des explications du maire
vaillancourt
oui est ce que monsieur vaillancourt des
présent
[Musique]
sans succès
l'ancien maire claude lefebvre lui est
aujourd'hui décédé nos documents nous
apprennent qu'il a fermé définitivement
son compte bancaire en suisse deux
semaines après la diffusion de son
entrevue à l'émission enquête des
centaines de milliers de dollars sont
alors transférés vers une autre banque
en suisse nous avons découvert ou sont à
des ces fonds
si les lavallois veulent de centre-ville
développer un commerce c'est un autre
politicien de laval
daniel defert s'est présenté à deux
reprises à la mairie de laval contre
gilles vaillancourt dont il est un
farouche opposant je suis intervenu
auprès des affaires municipales heures
dénonçant certaines situations daniel
lefebvre est le fils de l'ex maire
claude ulysse lefebvre les centaines de
milliers de dollars que son père caché
dans le compte de banque d'une fondation
du liechtenstein ont abouti dans son
propre compte bancaire ou credit suisse
il a accepté de nous rencontrer mais
sans caméras
le lendemain nous reparlons à daniel
lefebvre au téléphone il dit finalement
avoir reçu de l'argent de la fondation
du liechtenstein mais ignorer que ces
fonds appartenaient à son père
c'est pierre lambert qui a orchestré le
transfert de fonds entre claude lefebvre
et son fils
les documents que nous avons obtenus
montrent clairement que c'est lui qui
communique avec les banquiers ça ajoute
l'intérêt à enquêter sur l'avocat dans
ce cas depuis combien de temps et de
quelle manière et combien d'argent on ce
n'est pas quelques 5000 $ du maire de
combien d'argent c'était avocat là
auraient transiger finalement on se fait
partout
ces nouveaux faits pourrait également
déclenché une enquête disciplinaire du
syndic du barreau le chien de garde des
avocats et syndicats dont seulement
devraient préoccuper on peut faire un
cas une gelée dès jeudi je vous le dirai
même que dans une telle situation
vu l'impact sur le public je pense qu'un
syndic non seulement eux mais devrait
amorcer minogue et
si c'est le cas les règles de l'enquète
seront différentes les professionnels de
l'obligation de collaborer à une enquête
du syndic
l'obligation de fournir les
renseignements les années document
demandé de donner accès à son dossier
si les convois pied il ya l'obligation
de se présenter devant le syndic alors
oui et l'obligation collaboration
contrairement droit criminel le
professionnel n'est pas drôle silence
puisque d'autres partis et donc personne
qui ne sont pas des professionnels
pourrait être forcée a collaboré aussi
ou à témoigner je pense par exemple à
monsieur vaillancourt absolument devant
nous révélation la ville de laval
examine tous ses recours y compris
contre gilles vaillancourt si on a eu
une entente monsieur vaillancourt et
dans l'entente qu'a cette crainte qui
avaient des prêts venant de l'argent
caché mon ami une clause est très
importante en disant que si dans la
déclaration de ses actifs il leur dit
pas toute la vérité l'entente tombe on
garde l'argent et on pourrait intenter
des poursuites donc en remettre pierre
lambert de bien vouloir s'approcher
pierre lambert a été radié deux ans du
barreau pour les faits qu'il a reconnus
à la commission charbonneau
depuis il a retrouvé son droit de
pratique au cours des dernières semaines
il a quitté laval il a vendu sa luxueuse
maison sur le bord de la rivière des
prairies pour 2 millions de dollars on
ignore ce qui est advenu des cinq
millions et demi de dollars qu'il
détenait en suisse
au téléphone il dit souhaiter tirer un
trait sur son passé
[Musique]
après huit ans au pouvoir marc demers si
son équipe ont réussi à récupérer 50
millions de dollars volés durant l'ère
vaillancourt il est malgré tout
convaincu qu'il y ait encore de l'argent
caché j'ai une opinion qui est qui et
bien personnel je pense qu'on peut
penser que les conséquences se
traduisent en interne de centaines de
millions marc demers ne se représentait
pas aux élections municipales
la suite de l'histoire appartient à son
successeur
fini et que j ai pas fini là je parle
point interne de continuer quelques
semaines ou quelques mois je n'ai
prescience un chantier qui va durer
quelques années
[Musique]